foreign
[Music]
it is a pleasure to be presenting to the
bioprocessing UK
2022 my name is Leonardo Rios
I am based at the University of
Edinburgh
enter for synthetic and system biology
and but then all those recently I would
be moving to the university in April so
very soon
University of Newcastle
so just yet just to let you know you
know for sorry for further updates if
you want to be in touch with me I will
be moving through the school of natural
environmental science and I was moving
that as a senior lecturer so I'm quite
excited about that
so well I mean what my group is is
really working is in the interface of
synthetic biology where we see a little
bit in the left you know like uh have
using engineering principles to design
biosystems and especially in my case
microbial cell factories
but we combine that also with with
bioprocessing Technologies how when can
we scale up those systems in a
sustainable and also economical way
so so then that's a little bit the two
expertise of my group and so yeah that's
where the talk the name of this talk is
yeah leveraging
uh how can we achieve this emerging you
know and especially using micro scale
tools microscale bioreactors
to quickly let's say design those
systems and then scale in them up in a
rapid way and this talk we're gonna
Focus specifically about some ball we
had done with an anti-cancer drug called
taxol
which is one of the most widely used
natural molecules used for curing many
many cancer diseases but then still not
producing a very sustainable way so we
will find that we would love to produce
it using microbial cell factories but
also in a cheaper way
so as I said you know in my in my group
what we do first is we develop
interesting natural products from plants
in these cases anti-cancer drug taxol
which I want it was not also who
discovered that you know that in already
previously discovered so then how can we
produce it in a sustainable way and
ideally some of the tools that we are
developing some of our methodologies to
scale up and production of those systems
will help to reach a circular economy
where we don't produce any waste and and
then those same tools could be applied
to let's say other type of molecules
like biofuels where the market is a lot
bigger and it it can really have an
impact in in this area
and then okay going back to taxol so
taxolymers from that because
taxes many different taxes species we
can find them easily here in Scotland
you may have seen them if you are from
this area with those lovely little
berries so the taxes is mainly produced
in the in the needles
of those trees
before they used to take the three
whole bark and they had to get lots of
different trees to produce a single dose
of of this this drug so they actually
they almost got extinct sometimes all
those trees now they are a bit more
advanced in metals where they use the
needle and they extract an intermediary
of the Dark Soul and then from a
chemical synthesis synthesis
they obtain the text also it's a
semi-synthesis you know same is still
providing natural resources and
semi-synthesis that we would like to
make it totally not have to rely at all
on on trees and produce it in unlike
organisms in this case sslvci
and so part of the first work which
we're not going to go very deep in this
case but that's part of also about the
Martinez how to build this microbial
cell factories you can see there the
whole the whole pathway and we haven't
actually reached the full taxol molecule
yet you know there's still steps to
discover
to this molecule we are almost in the 10
beta hydroxylase State and as you can
see some of the genes in green have been
over expressed they come from the plant
would have been overexpressed some of
the genes in Orange
we build different microorganisms some
of the genes in red
we have put several copies of it and
yeah we're excited we are we're one of
the uh groups that have reached one of
the furthest steps using the microbial
cell factories uh and then okay we're
ready to start
scaling and try to produce those
intermediaries in a bit larger scale
and so how do we proceed
to do that so that was one of my
PhD students and now she's opposed in my
group know that Laura was for expertise
was how to use different micro scale
bioreactors to rapidly optimize those
systems you know after we build them
how to see all the effect of the
different bioprocessing bugles variables
in those systems but we want to use them
in a small scale tools so that they can
mimic larger scalar reactors so some of
those examples are here some we can use
some micro plates that they have
integrated sensors and that the shape of
the well will mimic will give enough
oxygen for example or will mimic the
fluid dynamics of a larger scale system
and then okay with also some minibio
reactor series from the applicant 250
milliliters ones but they totally mimic
really well you know they have all this
impeller shade of stress it we make
quite well a larger scale system
so we wanted to leverage those tools to
see you know like how valuable it was
that quickly optimize those those
materials or factories
Lotus proposed approach was first to do
some uh trial experiments in shape last
so not start immediately from a smaller
scaling going to larger scale but for
some some trial experiments with inner
shape flasks to to test some extreme
conditions on non-extreme conditions and
see how that's affecting ourselves first
because after you get this quick
information then yes with your design of
experiments
designer experiments to to vary
to see the effect of all the process
variables including pH
including oxygen including shaking speed
including no problem concentration
including all the different media
components including temperature in
addition to you know we could also put
different strains you know the different
genome you know engineering strengths
that we have done so that that adds
quite a lot you know so that's what you
mean we do some trial experiment to see
and then and then yeah we do the design
of the experiments and we're not going
to go deep into all the design
experimental optimization that was on
here just highlight in this methodology
that worked really well after that okay
then we did the scallop in some of the
largest levels but
type of data that we would get here
we're showing a little bit some of the
we could start to see some of the
bottlenecks of the data first you know
we could see that biomass how depending
on the different Medias and components
we have higher or lower biomass we
wanted to go higher we could see the pH
usually pH is totally neglected we could
see how the pH changes were totally
affecting the whole pathway and we could
see which pH was affecting more one type
of enzyme and not another enzymes you
know we have different enzymes from
different microorganisms so the pH has a
different effect on each one of those so
it was about finding a trade-off you
know like uh so you want to affect maybe
the one that is the the one to affect
less the one that is the key enzyme you
sell the bottleneck of your pathway and
then after you relieve that one you you
may see which one is the next modern leg
and going to that you know oxygen
dissolved with oxygen was also very
interesting for us to see how it was
actually critical not only for I mean
our yeast isn't needed so oxygen to grow
you know we wanted to keep it in a
fermented metabolism but but it was
actually more critical for some of the
enzymes that were talking about p450s
were doing they needed some oxygen some
of them and that was key to really also
improve this and this bad way so and
then okay what we did in the bottom of
the metabolomics and we saw that the
process variables had a huge impact of
the metabolomics profile that we were
getting
especially because when you're putting
those Pathways from planting to yes for
example you may get many side products
and unwanted products and then the way
then and then those are different for
your processing and
variables have a have a big effect on
the amount and type of unwanted products
that you want to know so that you have
to minimize those and and get the
product specifically that you want
so after that's been successfully done
the advantages you can model also that
too we could model uh both biomass
border stops you know the software
consumption ethanol and also the product
product production you know we could
model it to our certain degree we can
get the you know the coefficients of
product to biomass product to substrate
and that's good enough for us then to do
calculations to look at this scaling up
and or also starting to think about
different type of bioreactors you know
and that's what we realize in our case a
continuous flow by a reactor would be
the ideal based on this model it was
telling us our production product is
linked to the energy the metabolism this
is continually being produced with
growth uh Continuous Flow would be the
best way and so that was all then after
getting this information is how to
design this continuous lower reactor
that was to be the task of my other PhD
student Jorge Jorge santoyo it was okay
to tell us how to do an integrated
bioprocessing where we can continuously
grow the cells and produce
our product but also the same time we
needed to continuously remove
the product you know I mean it's fine to
keep growing the cells continuously but
if you cannot keep recovering the
product continuously then it's it's
useless you know so that was a task
of orchid how how to achieve that
normally the way we were growing and
removing our product is we were doing
that we're using an organic overlay into
the you know we have our bladder with
our media our cells we were using
dodecaine on top of it so we could then
remove
our product is totally hydrophobic so
you will go to the dollar cane and from
the other cane we will purify our
compound
but that that's an environmentally not
friendly and actually to produce our
compound to to Really purifiable
compartment was extremely difficult it's
very difficult to evaporate but again
so and then when you're going to a
continuous flow system mixture of water
without a cane it's impossible really to
keep continually separating
so jorgeous had the idea then to use a
solid liquid extraction so using beads
in these cases he selected to use HP 20
resin beat
we actually try other beats but we got
very interesting data that we we may we
may patent or not the result so we
couldn't show some of the rest of the
other bits get and that was exciting but
we can show the results of that one that
this work has been published recently
and the idea is you have the yeast to
feed them in this case galactose now we
have experience that control and glucose
or raffinos and because the whole
engineer pathway inside but when it
produces taxadine or other different
intermediates we have to select a bit
that will selectively absorb the
taxadine
so it will allow us to work in a
bioreactor setting like this one we're
controlling all the bioprocess
parameters at Laura obtained it will
grow in the beads at the same time first
as the yeast so we that's a preliminary
step before moving to continuous flow
system
first you want to try just you know that
you're you're in C2 methods to remove
the compound that it works and you want
to optimize it at first and so so Jorge
did that you know firstly developed you
know the fermentation step in the left
it's growing the the cells the beads but
then he had to develop a whole method to
extract you know like the products from
the beads for example you know so it's
this whole thing you know like growing
the cells so then the beads are easily
recordable or easy to recover from the
fermentation system and then you need to
find a way to recover
and in this case that intermediates of
Dark Souls so he did that but first he
tried to test okay the concentration of
Beats does it have an effect
it will grow in the beats with the yeast
and see we have a graph when we try
different concentration of bits and we
see the growth of the microorganism with
time we can see they grow fairly well
except with the dashed line which is
after 12 percent of resin beads the
cells they totally died that was in the
micro scale that was in the shake flasks
and so after further investigation we
discovered that the bits they were
actually if you see in the left that's
when we stopped the fermentation the
bits are actually quite big in
comparison to a cell the biggest big is
the quite big one and the cells use
sensors liquid mode but when you start
doing the fermentation with time with
impeller or juice shake flasks which was
in this case a micro scale and the beads
start to break and they create some
small little fragments that kills the
cells if they break the cells are quite
actually is more than they work as
needles that were killing the cells so
so then yeah if you put many of those
bits there is a balance you will then
totally crush the culture so you cannot
add more than 12 percent without you
know like having a killing them the
cells so but okay we saw that okay it
works with a three six percent uh this
so that was fine and then okay then we
started you know like where is it really
all our taxiding and and
and in transport intermediates moving to
the to the Beats so with this case we
separated the liquid phase from the
solid phase and there was almost known
taxa Line and other uh how you call it
here like uh attack from intermediate in
the liquid phase and in this case it's
important to say the solid phase was the
cells plus the beads so there were both
together you know it was just separated
liquid it was a solid phase and we go so
that everything was in there but things
could be the product could be in the
cells or it could be in the beads you
know so that was a question that we were
not so sure about it so then in this
graph as you can see in the board middle
middle you have how much of the taxadine
was staying in the bits that's the
middle one left and then the middle one
right is how much was it staying in the
biomass
and then you can see in the right the
the gray one is the total one you know
beats plus bio bus together
if you sell me normally the Beats plus
the biomass it should match your answer
Max balance you know it should match
when you you know the one the Beats plus
biomass you know but then when we were
separating the beats and the biomass
that is inherently some by you know some
steps and extra step and some of the
texture line is easy to evaporate some
of it is lost you know you cannot
clearly separate everything so nicely so
there are some losses and that's why
we're not getting the the exact mass
balance of how much is in bits plus the
biomass should be equal to the bigger
gray but the key thing is to say that it
was half half
child forms of the taxation was in the
Beats half was still in the biomass so
that was a key very interesting thing to
see you know it means that not
everything was totally in the Beats you
know interestingly also to say that we
produced a lot more almost a double and
more than a double that we were using
our daughter cane system so this method
was a lot nicer it is less toxic you
know dodecan is a bit toxic to the cells
this one's less toxic and they were
quite happy to see there was actually a
lot more efficient uh producing than the
the red one the orange one you know
again and so then okay then we developed
just a method to so how to extract you
know now we recover it from the beats
that that how are we gonna totally start
the taxadine we try different organic
solvents that are no elasticity
elasticate dollar can you know the same
one that that and we actually started
using acetone was a lot better than the
traditional method you know using
dodecaine or retina tested and that was
because there was a trade-off acetone
was very good to extract from the beats
but it was also breaking the cells very
nicely
and recovering all the taxation inside
the cells so it was like a two-step
process using one row you know breaking
the cells to remove the that's right
from there and also from the beads so
that was that was a fantastic for an
integrated bio process you know so then
that worked really well
we tested also we wanted to see okay
what we're using in this case three
percent of bits can we go lower you know
maybe maybe one maybe 0.1 percent I mean
these are a bit expensive you know so
how much can we go lower and we were
okay interesting please to see that you
can actually go to point one as you can
see in the right I mean the growth there
is no effect at all in the growth this
is the growth of the cells with
different concentrations from three to
point one no statistical difference
production rate three percent was still
better than 0.1 and one percent uh but
not drastically better you know we're
talking a little that was almost a
double so so that would totally depend
you know the of the value of the product
of the Techno economics we've seen that
yeah the morbids we have we still we
push to have better recovery and but if
the expenses of the Beats is critical
you can go to very low and still get a
good good recovery of the yield and then
I mean that has to do with many other
things because we then discovered so
that's something that we cannot show
here that we were surprised to see that
some of the bids they have or other more
beneficial effects
not only they were recovering
taxa line but they were also helping the
cells to be more healthy and we when we
investigating that we have other bits
that promote that but that's still
confidential we cannot say that that was
a that was interesting to see that you
know the Beats can have further
advantages than just that's three
interest helping you to purify the
compounds so that's those are very great
news and we will be happy to present
those things after you know we have
protect and then we have also published
that new data in this case we can only
show that and the effect of this
specific deeds and but then okay then we
proceeded to scale up in a fermented uh
we were bright pleased to see that uh
the rest of them were getting in a small
scale they were I mean they were even in
our case we've been even better you know
so we have a micro plate perceptible
reactor we were consistent and even a
bit better in the larger scale was
actually quite nice to see that in using
all the optimized pH oxygen conditions
uh so that word gets very nicely so that
was really good we were happy to to get
that and publish it and then the next
step in collaboration with Dr Simone di
Martino from Edinburgh University we
moved towards The Continuous Flow
production
of this this system and in this case and
we've been thinking about putting the
beats in a column and I just put the
bits in a column so that we will be
recirculating then the cells in a column
and
but then okay it's going to be like a
packet pad column so the beads won't be
into the solution with all the mixers so
then they won't be breaking apart
killing the cells and that's virtual
study does the transition to go towards
Continuous Flow
production system
and there are challenges to be there so
for example the column depending on the
flow rate the column will get back and
you can get blocked the depending how
much you know the the beat type that you
use the density and the flow rate the
column will expand and then get blocked
so there is some optimization chartings
to do that and so then also this is a
also a bit work working for all cases a
few things that we cannot show yet
because it hasn't yet been published
some of those but some of the very
interesting vessels that we have shown
that I can show here is for example
uh in this graph we'll again the testing
the concentration of bits uh in higher
concentration you know like 19.2 was a
concentration of grams that was the
concentration of 12 when the bits in a
batch they were all dying in this case
when we put them in the in not
recirculating but in the vector that's a
blue line
so then the cells they totally die same
as it was happening when we were going
to circle asking about your reactor and
the right is the galactose you know they
consume but in this case we can put a
higher amount of beets into the
bioreactor if it's recirculated and the
cells that won't die and then the cells
they will actually grow very nice and
actually they will grow even nicer than
the control
which is some of those beneficial things
that I've been talking to you that we
were quite surprised we've been finding
out what are all those benefits and
benefits that and so still confidential
but is that we can really eat so
interesting and it also only help to
remove the the compound of interest but
it has a chance to be held here
uh so then running those systems
we got for example the 12 percent
in the middle for example if it's the 12
percent
uh ERC you know it's the internal uh you
know growing putting the Beats inside
the system you know like shaking with
the bits and the use growing at the same
time so they died they don't produce
almost anything three percent so we were
doing a bit before we were you know a
lower amount of beats in a bioreactor we
were able to produce
uh some of those in the cell some of the
similar amount in the absorber but with
the recirculation system we could go a
lot higher in the concentration of
absorber especially and in this case
actually the balance shifted the
majority of our product would stay in
the absorber and almost nothing inside
the cells because we could really then
put a lot more concentration of uh of
the absorber so that was actually very
promising because it it helped us to
purify it more easily we can go a lot
more aggressive in the amount of bits
that can be put we can put and then
that's an enable us you know to develop
then those Continuous Flow systems that
that we are now finishing and hopefully
we will present hopefully next year
after we can publish all the latest
interesting vessels about that and then
okay to tend to finishing with this we
just want to conclude you know that
we're totally convinced that integrated
by your processing will be crucial for
the future of value manufacturing
especially towards this shift to
Continuous Flow we're totally convinced
that this will really lower down the
costs by at least one fall you know to
10 folds and and folders and and then
that will really make many things
economically viable using biotechnology
that we wanted to discussion that the
characterization of the of all those
individual units of operations you know
for the
extraction and the growth of the cells
and the different conditions the
parallel it's very necessary it involves
lots of different experiments so using
microscale tools using these kind of
experiments is quite necessary and we
were quite pleased to see that when you
are integrating those Upstream
Downstream
radical positive effect on the Austrian
section if properly integrated and that
can be actually a lot very interesting
you know to even improve the economics
of the process
what are some of the then also
challenges that we are now tackling or
at least characterizing is for the
continuous system is then kinetics of
the mutation rates of our synthetic
Pathways one of the the model Next Level
continuous position I have so can we
minimize those can we or at least
predict them so we can find ways to to
minimize that is some of the work that
we are doing to to
future work you know to tend to be able
to really be able to change this to the
manufacturing so finishing with that
yeah I would like to acknowledge
uh all my PhD students Paul Stock
students and this work especially in
this case Laura uh holiday or
fundamental but then us correlate
forehead also participated a lot and
especially to Raphael from from the
Simone's group
participated quite a lot uh funding that
we have got from different sources ddsrc
dpsrc Global challenge funded and
collaborators from universities in
Mexico Empire College Berkeley Denmark
University was critical for this work
and and many other uh support
thank you very much